in Gwynn's age of fire there were four
notes who distinguished themselves above
all others
first there was Hawkeye Goff who fought
in the first war against the Dragons he
exalted in the thrill of the hunt
plucking dragons out of the sky
with his enormous great boat soon the
only dragons left were in his memories
which he revisited endlessly fighting on
the ground was on Steam the Dragon
Slayer he wielded a long lightning cross
spear that could be stamped deep into
his stone dragon's hide it's curious
design went on to remind many of an
exiled God of War though none of them
dared to speak his name
and then there was Kieran whose talents
differed considerably from the previous
to a stealthy assassin she would have
been no match for dragons and so she
must have killed Ferg win in the age of
fire to follow she dazzled her foes with
streaks of gold in the night and then
stung with the vicious poison of her
silver tracer but in the age of man to
come none were as well-equipped as the
great Knight Artorias
for nothing not dragons nor disunity nor
even his enemies frightened Gwyn like
the dark the dark soul of man filled the
Lord of Light with fear for one day Gwyn
knew the fire would fade and humanity
would inherit the world his world so
while he still had time and power Gwyn
began to rink the world in his favor
mankind had stood amongst those who set
out to slay the ancient dragons and as
if in thanks Gwyn bestowed upon pygmies
and men the ringed City an enormous
skill did city located at World's End
the walls were as tall as mountains and
above them sword Medea an immortal arch
dragon that was raised by the gods below
slumbered Gwynn's youngest daughter the
princess fillion or a woman of enormous
faith and power who Gwyn gave up to
protect the pygmies until the very end
of the world and at first glance you
might think these acts benevolent you
might think they were kind but in the
end it was just a trick of the light
the walls were not for protection dragon
had an eternal duty to battle the dark
and Gwynn's daughter
philia nor would never see her father
again the purpose of the ringed City was
not to protect the holders of the
original Dark Soul it was to imprison
them like a ring of fire that encircles
the darkness of humanity and man was in
fact branded with this very seal the
dark sign and despite clear evidence of
their heroism in the war against the
Dragons their dark knights never were
lauded for their service so it's no
wonder then that in all of the
spellcraft and the hexes that stem from
humanity one thing remains constant it
craves a free will of its own and it
rides against its shackles perhaps the
first example of this was the Mad King
he was pygmy royalty and he rebelled
against the light we have no idea what
crimes he committed but they must have
been terrible for he was put to death by
Shira the night of fillion or only the
Mad King would not die and Shira with
the Mad King impossibly entwined around
her spear had no choice but to hold him
quietly in a dark room
till the end of time there were of
course other human cities outside of the
ring city one such example was the dark
city of New Londo which was governed by
for human kings and protected by Knights
of the dark blade the Kings were
renowned for their foresight and they
even had fragments of Guin's very own
soul bestowed upon them so that they
could better govern their people of
course
this too was another trick of the light
for what lies at the top of New Londo
but filing shrine a place of undead
sacrifice to Gwynn's
age of fire so no human city was
permitted to flourish without a clear
benefit to the age of fire and there was
no better example of this than another
human city called
all the seal which was a golden land of
light sorceries light it turns out can
be manipulated to foster illusions it
can hide your intentions it can even
mess with the fabric of time and spells
of this nature would be of great value
to the gods in the coming years so will
the seal flourished an exemplary city
for Gwynn's Pantheon because it was
proof that humanity could be taught to
serve their interests and so it was that
a group of missionaries from all the
seal embarked upon the ringed City
perhaps to preach and reinforce the
power of the light in this dark City one
of these missionaries was called half
light and he was a talented individual
who was wielding the powerful artifacts
of his homeland he would go on to earn
the favor of Fillion or and he would
even earn the legendary dragon weapon of
Medea so it was no surprise that
half-light elected to stay behind
becoming the last recorded spear of the
church and just as half-light visited
the ringed city and even stayed behind
the reverse was also true of a certain
pygmy from the ringed city this pygmies
name was manis and while we know nothing
about the name
of his visit to all asil we do know one
thing he died there and the body of
primeval man of Manas was put to rest
far far beneath the city itself out of
the light and out of mind we don't know
much about Manas and a lot has left to
the imagination what we do know is that
he was a pygmy far from home he was a
part of a race that Gwyn was doing
everything in his power to suppress and
when you think on manases fate it's kind
of hard to imagine that Gwyn didn't have
a hand in it especially since Gwyn had
an order of assassins the Lord's blades
in his employee the leader of the Lord's
blades was keyed on the Hornet it stated
that she laid waste to Gwynn's enemies
and of course there's no proof that the
Lord's blades actually killed Manas but
you could also argue that that's rather
the point of assassins isn't it
whatever the case the tide was turning
mankind was struggling against the world
order and even New Londo which was once
a haven for Undead had turned into a
hideous spawning ground for the abyss
and its darkwraiths at the heart of this
uprising was a serpent named Kath who
swayed the four kings and taught its
undead Knights how to pillage back their
humanity some descriptions even say the
darkwraiths became the most human of all
but to others the darker deaths are the
enemies of men and any living thing that
has a soul
so as the age of man crept ever closer
yet another night of Gwyn appeared
perfectly equipped to face it the great
knight artorias with a great sword
waited to strike harder against servants
of the dark a great wolf who defined
their fighting style
the Covenant with the beasts of the
abyss knight artorias and SIF defiantly
faced the worst of mankind yet in the
end the terror that was the darkwraiths
could only be stifled with the sacrifice
of their entire city such was the power
of their four kings and the resilience
of their abyss like a leaf a Gwyn such a
safety measure had been put in place
years ago and so the sealers of New
Londo
watched historically as water rushed
into the city and thousands of innocents
died by their hand the entire city was
sacrificed to contain them for that is
how great a threat they were but while
Gwyn did manage to put the New Londo
threat on hold no one was prepared for
the outbreak in all Aseel I imagine when
they figured out that a primeval human
was buried beneath their very City the
temptation must have been too great to
resist believe it or not
you Lucille has brought the abyss upon
itself fooled by that two-faced serpent
they upturned the grave of primeval man
and incited his Warner in Wrath what
could they have been thinking like the
mad pygmy King before him Manus rejected
death and he was as far from pieces
could be the raw emotion of humanity
that we mentioned earlier billowed
outwards corrupting the townsfolk of
oolacile and Manus became the father of
an unstoppable dark abyss curiously
though it's almost as if he was
searching for something using his power
to reach across time and space until he
found it instead he found dusk princess
of oolacile I still think on that
creature from the abyss that preyed upon
me my faculties were far from lucid but
I quite clearly sensed certain
emotions a wrenching nostalgia I lost
joy an object of obsession and a sincere
hope to reclaim it could these thoughts
belong to the beast from the abyss but
if that were true then perhaps it is no
beast after all the object of his
obsession was a pendant and with it in
our possession
we're pulled back back to a time where
wall appears lost well look at this one
from what faraway Age has thou come I
sent his very human indeed but not
intolerable I am Elizabeth guardian of
this sanctuary thou shalt see further on
an abyss was begat of the ancient beasts
and threatens to swallow the whole of
oolacile the city is lost the abyss is
spreading and mankind has succumbed to
the worst parts of their nature when
Gwyn heard of Manas and his abyss
Artorius must have been the first one
sent to deal with the threat he was
after all the best-equipped
but fighting darkwraiths is considerably
different to the power of primeval man
so artorias was bested and was forced to
retreat
beset by the abyss the final act of
artorias was to protect his companion he
shielded SIF with the divine power of
his great shield after all his arm was
broken and he could no longer bear the
burden then notorious himself was
overcome forgive me knight artorias came
to stop this but such a hero has nerium
murmur of dark without doubt he will be
swallowed by the abyss overcome by its
utter blackness indeed the abyss may be
unstoppable all was lost and yet
strangely soon after the spread of the
abyss was actually halted and Princess
dusk of oolacile miraculously wandered
out of the abyss Artorius his name
henceforth passed into legend the knight
who gave His life to disperse the abyss
to rescue the princess of all the seal
this is a lie of course
in reality it is we who rescued the
princess and we fulfilled the legacy of
artorias this may strike thine ear as
somewhat peculiar but long ago in my
home land of oolacile
I was beset by a creature from the abyss
I would have perished then were it not
for the great Knight Artorias
in truth I saw little of what transpired
for mine senses were already fled but
even still there was something about
artorias a certain balance of the humors
that quite perfectly fits your semblance
heavens could it be that with this
analysis suffering has ended but Manus
wasn't the only corruption of the abyss
that we killed in all the seal there was
also artorias the legend of artorias is
a lie he did not vanquish the father of
the abyss he did not eliminate the
darkwraiths of New Londo the abyss is
unstoppable and yet eons later the
legend of artorias would inspire a
legion of abyss watchers who continue to
rage against the dying of the light yes
the abyss is unstoppable
but they fight nonetheless even in this
state
notice that artorias continues to seek
out and kill corruptions of humanity
he's still in there somewhere
but his legend can only live on with his
death
[Applause]
only his fellow Knights knew the truth
but they would take his soul and his
secret to the grave and wallah Tauruses
soul was corrupted by the worst of
humanity it was the best of humanity
that redeemed it and the hero of all the
seal would disappear without a trace
almost as if he didn't belong for in
reality he didn't and eons later deep
within an enchanted wood behind two
locked doors and a troop of forest
protectors an ancient cat speaks the
truth the legend of artorias at none but
a fabrication traversing the dark tis
but a fairy tale Alvina is keen to
downplay the legend of artorias because
heroes and bandits have begun seeking
out his grave they would desecrate his
legacy for the secret of abyss walking
and they may do harm to SIF who in fact
Alvina helped you rescue back when the
world was still young imagine what SIF
is feeling when you cross paths again
years later you're duty-bound to seek
the abyss and SIF is duty-bound to stop
you one of you will have to die because
SIF cannot give you the Covenant of
artorias willingly maybe in death he can
find his friend artorias again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
before I go I just want to say a couple
more things firstly this video was made
far far better by the contributions of a
guy called the Perry God who recorded
footage for me this time it allowed me
to sort of focus more on the script and
the Edit he's responsible for those
fantastic slow-motion shots which I
didn't know how to do but they fit
really really well with the pacing of
the video so do me a favor and please go
watch his cinematic short film on Dark
Souls 3 because it's inspiring stuff
he's just getting his channel started
and his upcoming work is really well
worth your subscription in my opinion
and this is an appropriate video to
shout out somebody else's channel in
because all those years ago this video
prepared to cry Artorius this was the
story I decided to tell for the first
time and this is the video that got my
channel started so being able to work on
this again after everything I've learnt
was really special for me and I really
appreciate that you watched it all the
way through I hope you enjoyed it and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you